tonight's panel is basically starting a
business while you're a student at
Carnegie Mellon a number of people are
able to do that number when people
aren't able to do that so tonight you're
going to hear the pros and cons and
difficulties of doing it all of the
people on our panel or have done it or
are doing it currently and they're going
to tell you their experiences my main
job tonight added and welcome milk
welcoming you thank you for being here
and thanking the panel is to introduce
Steve Steve black is going to be
moderating the panel this evening and he
is a 04 graduate from the tempered
school and I've had the pleasure of
working with Steve and founding his
company and being on the board during
that whole period of time so I'm pretty
familiar with what he's been able to do
he's found her account medical solutions
which was launched during his tenure
here at The Temper school and basically
clear town has developed and deploys the
world's first fda-approved RFID solution
for platform dealing with patient safety
in a hospital system clerk count has
raised technology-based economic
development funding they've done some
food strapping the SBIR zip done angel
funding have done venture funding over
this period of time and so he's been
through the wolf process the company
itself has been reached recently
featured time magazine named as wired
magazine's ten best uses for rfid runner
up in this year's Wall Street Journal
technology awards category and selected
they too
nine winner of best of what's new by
popular science so without further ado
Steve luck thank you all welcome to
Global Entrepreneurship Week and welcome
to our panel our panels title today is
starting a company as a student at
Carnegie Mellon as our just informed you
I was lucky enough to be able to do that
while I was here at the temper school
from 03 204 but we have a very
distinguished and diverse panel of
entrepreneurs who have also done this
and as I think as you get more familiar
with the CMU community you'll understand
that this is actually something that's
not too uncommon there's every year a
lot of businesses spin out of Carnegie
Mellon I think the statistic I saw was
an average of three per year that's
correct well it's really more like 10 to
15 this modal ok the student generated
component is probably more like five or
plus ok so so it's very exciting we're
very honored to have this distinguished
panel to kind of pick their brains and
understand a little bit about what their
experiences were while at CMU of just a
quick 30 second background of my own
connection with Carnegie Mellon I
actually was introduced to the idea of
entrepreneurship at CMU well before I
attended school here my brother actually
attended Carnegie Mellon's and spun out
of business back in 1995 a software
company which he was able to exit an
insult to a company here at Pittsburgh
on management science associates so
maybe it was a bit of civil sibling
rivalry that I felt like I was
challenged to come back and do it myself
unfortunately he was able to do it
bootstrapping it as many of these
entrepreneurs have whereas Claire counts
had to raise over eight million dollars
in capital so that's a long painful
lesson in fundraising there but you know
before I came to CMU I was a vaguely
aware of
success stories you hear about some of
the big ones in recent years red zone
some companies like Molly's trolleys I
saw the trolley parked right outside
here that's another CMU connection there
Plex Tronics so you hear about the
success stories but you don't really
hear about just how many diverse
different companies there really are as
art said 10 to 15 per year is pretty
pretty incredible and pretty impressive
so without further ado I would like to
get to the panel to sort of pick their
brains and understand you know what
makes Carnegie Mellon different and
unique and what really breeds success
here at CMU as compared to sort of the
general population of entrepreneurs so
with that being said I'd like to go down
the panel maybe start here with Brian
and briefly introduce yourself tell us a
little bit about your company and and
what it is that you do and your
connection to Carnegie Mellon thanks to
my name is bryan caplan and the vice
president and co-founder for company
called collaborative fusion clive
diffusion is a software technology
company primarily focusing on the
management of personnel during disasters
our systems are in use around the
country to help mobilize personnel
assets resources and track them during
disasters so for example during
Hurricane Katrina or you know incidents
like that our systems help locate
individuals who might be able to respond
and provide assistance and then help
mobilize them in two locations I am a
graduate of the undergrad program here
at Carnegie Mellon in 2002 and eat it I
think that what we'll talk more about
later but i think that Carnegie mom
really gave a good foundation for me in
terms of entrepreneurship and and you
know the lessons I was able to learn
here really applicable out in the you
know out in the software world great
Thank You Nathan my name's nathan martin
i'm the CEO of a local software company
called deep local formally i was a
researcher at the studio pre for
creative inquiry which is not technology
research lab here that probably
you know of none of you know of we are
primarily a consulting company we
develop innovative marketing campaigns
sometimes for large brands and we work
underneath a lot of ad agencies
nationally internationally and then we
develop a few of our own products that
have recurring revenue mostly we try to
keep a really cool culture going on so
that we have artists and interesting
engineers coming through our company as
fast as possible so more than anything
work culture great thanks Jessica
Jessica Travis I'm founder of a company
called etcetera edutainment I actually
did a lot of work in the entertainment
Technology Center if that's a department
you guys are familiar with my work
surrounds is around using video games
for learning and why that works and etc
entertainment delivers game based
training to the industrial safety market
essentially you have millions of workers
even in this country in utilities
manufacturing construction health care
that are still being trained in a very
passive way meaning lectures or videos
and then they go into these dangerous
jobs and they're expected to perform
safely well it's not working it's
causing companies to the tune of 170
billion dollars a year because of these
incidents so we're basically trying to
take the proven effectiveness of flight
simulation and deliver it through video
games as an accessible and affordable
way to provide more effective training
great and David hi my name is david chen
i'm actually currently a student at
Carnegie Mellon and I study human
computer interaction and information
systems I'm a senior i'm a co-founder in
the CEO of a company called voila we
provide restaurant ecommerce solutions
basically what we do is currently if
your restaurant and you want to start on
sarte online ordering service you're
limited to your own website or a virtual
food court and we make it possible for
restaurants to connect with various
existing virtual food courts mobile
applications and also your own website
and basically start an affiliate network
around their online ordering services so
what consumers are exposed to it our
company started with project Olympus
which is a sort of a business incubator
within the School of Computer Science
and we just recently graduated from
alpha by law business incubator which is
part of innovation works I've also I've
been starting businesses for about
roughly a decade I started my first
business when I was 11 years old and
I've been starting many many businesses
since then my most recent business
before koala was a company called spree
v.v which is one of the top 50 websites
in South Korea and it's a discussion
forum hosting service okay we have to
ask everybody's wondering what was the
company when you were 11 years old my
first company was it's actually related
to video game content so I helped people
who develop content about video games to
create websites and monetize those
websites using advertising so we're
going to do a panel discussion for about
15 minutes I think and then we're going
to break it out into open Q&A so first
question for you guys and I think we'll
we'll start at the opposite end with
David this time we talk a lot in
business school curriculum about market
focus solutions and staying close to the
customer and all of you are young
entrepreneurs exceptional young
entrepreneurs in some cases many or most
of you were students while you started
your company so I wanted you to talk a
little bit about how do you do that how
do you stay close to the customer and
how do you really know your market and
be a student at the same time okay um
basically all the companies that I've
developed have been primarily software
companies and we employ a philosophy of
developing quickly and releasing small
iterations and getting feedback as soon
as possible from customers this way we
actually create software that people
want to use instead of software that we
think people want to use that's one of
the most common mistakes i think is for
especially those of us have technology
backgrounds we like to you know sit in a
room or talk with friends and say hey
we're going to be great if we could
create this technology service or
product that would do you know some
technical thing and it may sound great
but it's not necessarily what there's
not necessarily a market for that
service or product so by getting it out
there as soon as possible you're able to
get some feedback and actually develop
your product or service into something
that is feasible to market and doing
this as a student fortunately for
internet-based companies it's much
easier because you don't have to
necessarily make face-to-face contact
and developing relationships with your
customers a lot of it can be conducted
virtually for farella we actually had to
go out and go talk to restaurants we
currently have about 80 restaurants in
Pittsburgh Washington DC and
Philadelphia who are working with us and
we actually do go out and visit the
restaurants in person it's pretty tough
as a student to do that but it's
possible it's great Jessica um well we
really it's just really important to be
really really close to the customer we
started the company by going out and
getting contracts because I knew coming
from Carnegie Mellon that we could build
you the best biggest featured craziest
multiplayer game that you know because
we're training people to go to Pixar and
Electronic Arts and Ubisoft and so you
know for us it's important to elko as
some people know was one of our first
big clients and I if I could have slept
over at the loading docks I would have
it's we hang out with a lot of safety
people alone a lot of Union people I'm
trained to operate a forklift trained in
a lot of the safety areas and just spend
as much time trying to immerse yourself
in that world
understanding at the end of the day what
are you solving and always focus on that
is what I try to share with my team
because you cannot develop I can't
develop anything in a vacuum so it's
just that's the number one lesson that
I've learned stay really close to your
customer great Nick I wasn't a student
when I started my company I was an
artist in residence here and I'm old I'm
32 so I appreciate the young hang out a
sex of Adam you know um but the thing
that we do so the thing that makes us
very distinct is I used to run an art
group for about 10 years about a decade
and internationally exhibited art group
before I ran up and since I was 16 years
old I learned really quickly and the
reason I work a lot with artists and
theater people people who can meet
deadlines similar to what David said
it's really critical to iterate very
quickly to fail very quickly and to try
very quickly when I actually spun out of
university I spent the first year
listening to a lot of business advice
from local seasoned entrepreneurs and I
failed to commercialize the technology
I'd spent three to five years working on
which is an online mapping piece of
software I sort of was frustrated at
that point had burnt through the
economic development money I had sort of
through the advice aside and said okay I
know how to organize a group of people
to get stuff done so let's figure that
out and from there I started to
bootstrap my company and realize that
just like staying very customer focused
you have to deliver things on time that
are cool and great I knew we had
technologists we had to think about how
we were going to build a business so I
did that really by the DIY approach to
things running it just like a van and my
company right now is run just like a van
this morning we had waffle Wednesday's
where we invite anyone indoor office to
have waffles and free consulting and we
from that we build up clients like Nike
and Volkswagen very little things that
you do sort of incubate a culture
staying close to your customer clearly
with web-based software we have a few
products we are very immersed in those
industries we join the associations that
sort of speak to those industries we get
market ourselves to the magazines that
attack those industries you know very
much sort of stay focused on that market
but also sort of picking your battles
doing things very quickly iterating
failing fast we've failed a lot we have
two products that have recurring revenue
right now we've launched probably 20
products since i started my company
three and a half years ago so that means
18 have failed
entirely failed flat on their face but I
learned very quickly how to get that
product cycle down to about two weeks
wait to state for the record that 32 is
not old honey how are you for you state
31 okay see I'm still tall person here's
your agent Oh simple Brian Santa course
sure up I in some ways I agree with the
rest upon us otherwise I don't quite but
the industry that I'm is primarily
government and and first responder I
spent the last ten years or so I've been
involved in emergency preparedness
emergency response I spent time here at
Carnegie Mellon and austin city of
Pittsburgh working on ambulance and I
got a real appreciation for what happens
during disaster versus you never just
what happens during a 16-hour day
running running around an ambulance and
I think it's not you know the iterative
cycles are very important it's very
important to understand what your
customer wants but it's also very
important to be in a position of
knowledge about your customer one of the
things that we really pride ourselves on
is having a solution solved for the
customer before they even realize they
have the issues and so you know we the
individuals that that work for
collaborative fusion they're all
immersed in about a six month training
program where we go through a series of
exercises where we teach them incident
command systems we teach them some basic
first aid we do all these sorts of
courses which have absolutely nothing to
do with programming a piece of software
you know just sitting from puter but
which ensure that when a client calls or
someone call it says I'm having a
problem doing X they understand they can
put themselves in the position of that
client and say I understand why you're
trying to do that and here's where the
problems are where I understand what
you're trying to do and G that doesn't
look right let me see what I can do
about fixing it so I think you know not
only is is it important to be you know
in a position where you're you're able
to rapidly put out changes but also you
need to be in a position where you
understand exactly what it is that your
customer wants in a you know an
especially in government and also in the
safety folks they not they may not be
the most educated of individuals I mean
some of them are you know there's lots
of PhD government folks there's also a
lot of lots of
first responders who never went to
college and so you have to understand
the market and the education level of
your individuals as well when you're
developing our applications thanks
Nathan you touched on a key theme here
you said how important it is to get the
right group of people around here one of
the things I was wanting to discuss with
you is as a young entrepreneur or as a
student some of you how do you find
those key people and how do you attract
them to come and join your company when
you're just maybe a couple guys in a
business plan maybe you don't have the
funding to attract top talent you know
how do you do that so maybe we could
start with you sure and this will be
from my experience so you know you can
ignore all this but um you know my first
I started my company with three people
there were three of us founders two of
them are gone they chose not to do it so
I had to stick it out my first two
engineers of my company have since been
fire they were fantastic engineers
former heads at marconi like they led
project teams but they were not good at
our company so finding that right mix is
critical and that means you know we have
an open office we have eight people they
sit around together at desks they have
to roll their chair over the next person
say can you help me with this thing some
people try strategies like two people
working at one computer I mean all these
things require people to have very good
communication skills so for example
we're hiring it we hire very slowly we
hire almost entirely organically so we
try not to do job postings we just sort
of do word of mouth and we're lucky
enough that we've been able to recruit
people from yahoo and from apple who
have left this company stick Yahoo
everyone juice but who's left those
companies to to come to us so it's not
that big but they he didn't leave san
francisco to come to pittsburgh so
that's fairly impressive so the
challenge then is retaining those people
and I'm happy to say that we ought we do
a great job about primarily because we
build a culture that people that are
I've always tried to build a company
especially after that first year that I
would want to work out because I want to
hire people like me people who are
passionate about what they do want to do
great work and don't want to just sort
of sit through the day until five
o'clock rolls around because in waste a
day on Facebook great I want people who
just want to get things out and deliver
them as fast as possible so we have for
our company in our style of company we
deliver things really quickly which
means people feel a sense of ownership
everyone interacts face to face with
clients when
have them we set really short goals want
people to feel like one they have a
sense of ownership not just in stock but
in products feel like they're really
making something and real and people who
are great at building stuff across
disciplines art business whatever want
to have that sense of ownership and that
they're building something cool that
people are going to use or try to use so
really just it's for me it's been about
building a culture that just attracts
those people I tried it out locally
which is which has worked really well I
think as you scale up to larger sized
companies it gets really hard I had an
investor tell me once you know you're
hiring a great people the second you
people maybe know this you know a great
people once they start to hire be great
people be great people start to hire see
great people you just start sort of
going down and firing my first employee
was really challenging to do I'm lucky
that most of my employees I was able to
find jobs at other companies and place
them where they were more adequately
position to be but um but that's that's
a really hard thing and I think you have
to be able to ignore things like resumes
I don't interview based on a resume I
don't interview based on a college and I
don't interview based on qpa or GPA I
interview based on based on whether or
not I can talk and have a conversation
with someone they can tell me what
they're actually good at they can tell
me what their one thing in life is that
they're great at and they can tell me
what the last thing they program
sure David what stumped on you perhaps
as our youngest entrepreneur on the
panel has has aged ever been a challenge
for you attracting top talent and and
how have you dealt with that yeah i
would say age is a challenge in business
in general sometimes up to a certain
point I remember when I was you know
when I was 12 or 13 and I had to that's
ridiculous from setting back then my
company actually owned a data center and
we leased a basement space of an
Internet service provider made that into
our data center and we had to hire
technicians to sort of maintain that
data center and deal with all the
equipment there and actually asked my
dad for help here because I felt kind of
it'll be unusual for being a 12 year old
to go out there and interview people and
there will be potential issues with that
but I think yeah after you sort of when
you reach college age and especially if
you've proven yourself a little bit with
some experience in working and starting
businesses as well it's much easier to
sort of show that you know you're you're
capable person and people respect you as
long as you're able to you know do
everything everyone else is um in terms
of finding students to work with you
that's been a pretty challenging task
for all is a pretty young company but
we've actually had about 14 or 15
different people work with our team and
our current team size is about five
people when you work when you're a
student you have to sort of deal with a
lot of noise in that a lot of students
will say that they're very interested in
working with your company and they'll
really try too hard to sell themselves
but they're really not ready to work on
work in this kind of situation in a
startup business because it takes a lot
so what I've done is really look for
our students we have past experience
either starting a business we're even
starting an organization or some effort
that really has had results and go from
there also personal network is really
important some of our team I met our
Microsoft interns because I internet
microsoft and that sort of served as a
screening device to if they have an
internship at Microsoft you know they
have this minimum level of competency
one other we all feel like
underachievers here jessica bryan do you
have anything to add to this question of
you know how do you retain for how you
attract and retain key employees maybe
when you don't have a huge budget maybe
don't have a huge track record of
success for your company when I was in
my second company the IHC would been
anyway when I was doing my second
company one of the problems I had
primarily web development firm so this
was back in 94-95 and one of the
problems that that I had was on the
phone had no problem to do with the
clients but you show up in your you know
14 15 you say hey you know I'm I'm you
know I'm showing up to 18 18 I'm say I'm
going to build your website for you and
they say well no you're not you know you
know we're sure dad and ice not it's not
it's not like that one of these i found
was very helpful is I actually hired
somebody who was about 20 years older
than me and she came with me to the
meetings and that seemed to get me in
the door a lot better I think the key to
retaining talent or really anything is
you can no longer build a company from
just one person back in the 60s and 70s
I think there were it was easier in some
respects say you've got a fantastic idea
worry about the team later just kind of
put it together and go for it these days
it's all about having a team of people
around you who complement you you don't
want to have a team five programmers
that that's not going to get you
anywhere you guys all think like
programmers or girls you want to have
somebody who's good at marketing you
want to have somebody who's good at
operations programming finance whatever
it is you don't have to have all of the
things that you need
but you should have a little bit of
variation some of the nastiest fights
and arguments have had or with people
who have come to become not only good
friends of mine but also fantastic
employees and partners simply because we
have differing opinions and that's what
makes the company's better that that
sort of not violent but that strong
discourse about where people have
differing opinions that's how great
ideas are you know you come out of a
company I think it's really important to
have that type of that type of
give-and-take whenever you're looking
for employees you know ask me in two
years I'm still trying to figure it out
well we'll switch questions then for you
what you you all have the common thread
that you all were either at CMU or
affiliated with CMU what resources would
you say have helped you the most being
affiliated with CMU and the course of
starting your business and running your
business me um well I definitely
wouldn't be doing what I'm doing today
without Carnegie Mellon I was really
really inspired I sort of this starting
a company just sort of happened I was
going through the Masters of
entertainment technology program and
just had a hunch that I should come up
here and spend a lot of time in this
classroom and so I did I took probably
10 or 12 courses and marketing finance
and entrepreneurship here while I was
doing my my other masters entertainment
technology and so I was just really
really inspired by what was going on at
the ET c and wanted to figure out how we
could apply all of that coolness and
expertise to problems in other
industries and so you know I the
resources in not only Carnegie Mellon
but in in the community that's for
business community people are it's you
know there's there's like one person
that I really wanted to get a meeting
with and I just couldn't get a meeting I
mean it people are just so accessible
and
willing to help and talking with other
students and the faculty is really
really great the administration's really
really great different departments so
sure yes Anna Nathan you kind of came at
this from a completely different angle
for me from the art program what was
your experience like and what resources
were there for you vaccine experience of
trying to see change we run an artist
residency program and while CMU's
fantastic unfortunately coming out of
the College of Fine Arts why did my
undergraduate there then I came back in
and no foreign artist in residence was
there for three years running a research
project two years and went on when i was
there and sort of technology transfer
came to me rob conway who was there is
no longer there came to me and said hey
you know he's some interest in this
mapping stuff you're doing so I thought
okay well I don't know what that means I
don't know what technology transfer is I
don't even know who owns my intellectual
property and truly College of Fine Arts
is pretty clueless as to who owns their
intellectual property but you find out
really quickly that university kind of
does and you got to license it Oh or get
them to sign off and say you know you
can take this with you and it doesn't
matter typically in the art department
everything that you serve say I invented
this thing tech transfer comes back and
says we don't really care about it it's
great it's art and you can have it that
didn't happen in our case because we
mapping the sort of hot at the time we
had this online mapping software so so
then I sort of was interested in sort of
introduced very quickly to the world
over here right did I do nothing about
and a tech transfer um I think CMU was
was hugely helpful I think the art
department needs to learn how to educate
students and I talked to the Dean
Hillary Roberts and a lot about this in
sustainable arts practice because
artists are very much for businesses
they run their own marketing they are on
their own accounting they fill out
themselves and they manage their their
own entity but they forget that often
whenever they go and try to get funding
or sustaining other arts practices so
they end up in academia and so we have
an artist residency program that gets
our artists mingling with a lot of our
customers and we try to employ them
through our customers and our clients
and we we've been successful with that
but CMU initially I'll make it early
Lane was useful as a brand Carnegie
Mellon as a name got me indoors that I
wouldn't have normally gotten into
in a Morgan Stanley conference that was
invite only and people would talk to me
because I had a Carnegie Mellon business
card otherwise they would not have and
that's sad to say but it's truly useful
when you're starting a business you use
everything you possibly can to your
advantage so use that business card
whenever I could it is very very
valuable this is a very prestigious
university you know that so you need to
rely on that name a little bit when you
start a company especially when you're
fundraising in the interest of time I
think we're gonna ask one more question
and we're going to ask it of all the
panelists here and that is what piece of
advice would you give to either students
who are thinking about starting a
business or any first-time entrepreneur
based on your experiences and maybe some
of the mistakes you guys made along the
way and we'll start here with with Brian
thanks um can I say it takes and I think
all of you've heard this it takes at
least twice as long as you think and
four times as much money something like
that keep going it takes usually six or
eight times as long as you think and
probably ten times as much money as you
need you can really almost never raise
enough and you always want to be raising
it when you're when you don't need it
they learned that lesson now probably
two or three times and it doesn't get
any easier the second or third time
around it's it's absolutely critical
because that's what you're going to need
to to sustain your business and the
companies they can sustain themselves
over 5 10 years are the ones that really
succeed we've switched business models
now three or four times and the only way
we were able to do that till we finally
hit on the one that was going to be
successful was that we had enough money
behind us in terms of you know burn rate
to be able to keep going yeah sure learn
what you're good at and learn what your
passion is and build a company around
that and your likelihood of success is
far greater I that's my lesson
hang out with your customers know what I
love you know I just better to meet your
customer yeah mini depends on Western
Road no I have a transit product good is
like in software development you know
same what I think of a business plans
the same way if you don't know why this
really why each component of your
business plan is in there then you need
to go find out why and David yep I would
just say if you have a you know great
idea that you're passionate about or yet
but yes something you want to start go
out there and talk to people about it go
out there and get different perspectives
one of the best things we did was a go
into project Olympus and getting some
feedback right away and they made some
key introductions for us to get to where
we are today and don't be afraid of what
people have to say about the company
because you're going to hear about it
when you start it anyways what can I had
one thing so while you're here the one
thing that I didn't do enough when I was
an undergrad that I think is hugely
valuable as is i rely a lot i said on
artist and I really do and I think that
unfortunately people specialize so much
that they start to sort of you hopefully
you interact with art students and drama
students and everything else we actually
have while you're here at the University
once you end up at a company and a team
of software engineers it's going to get
harder to do that if you truly want to
innovate you need to have perspectives
from people that think differently than
you that's how innovation actually
happens by combining different
perspectives about things so have great
experiences and befriend people that
have great experiences they're different
than your own and that's something that
you can do at a university that's really
hard to do once you leave the university
so do that while you're here and try to
retain those relationships I did not
unfortunately it's great advice well at
this point we're going to open it up to
QA so if anybody has any questions yeah
um actually my question is probably at
you only but you kind of hit only in the
beginning you talked about you have
well to your 80 restaurants that kind of
visited so for initial rollout
especially leaving the school like
what's the process that you guys have
seen that happen or what you guys
encouraged because that's a modification
of that Commission oh you mean what is
the process to get from you create a lot
like people like it or whatever but
you're kind of small biz is you're not
able to national rollout tho i knows
what it is you're determined so I'm just
wanted a one go on fishing around people
what is your um I guess that depends on
what kind of visits you're running in
your business model and who's your
target customer and one of the ways to
find out in the beginning is to go out
and get different perspectives and meet
with potential customers and see if
there's a good fit and if it's feasible
for us we wanted to make it possible for
basically any mom-and-pop restaurant all
the way up to franchise restaurants to
be able to have online e-commerce
solutions so we went out there and
visited restaurants and I guess how we
got to go out there and actually get
those customers was when we entered into
the business incubator program at alpha
lab part of innovation works we set
goals with them that by the end of the
Alpha option we wanted to be making some
revenue and have a certain number of
customers and then we devised a plan to
go out there and do just that and for
the longest time before that we were
sort of stalling and wondering how we
could develop a product more before we
go out and get those customers but it
was pretty important for us to go out
there and get feedback so you're saying
just just go out and do it yeah well
that that works here I guess it depends
on your business if you're making a
medical device you can't just go out and
a little different but but how would you
get those those first customers to take
your calls and to meet with you for us
we actually used the Carnegie Mellon
name when we went to our first
restaurants we told them where
company that's starting out of Carnegie
Mellon University and we wanted them to
be one of our first customers and at the
time we had some press coverage some
newspaper articles about me and the
business and we also show them this and
that sort of made them more comfortable
about discussing a business relationship
and it made it seem like we're someone
sort of credible and not just a random
somebody puffing in more questions way
in the back no this idea is innovation
and it is something different and it is
very easy for someone that I n is an
underactive there are already
experienced people in that particular
whose what we want to work with that may
be the very end meet something bigger
before you can actually I feel like
there's a tendency for entrepreneurs to
feel like their ideas are the biggest
secret ever and they need to keep it to
themselves and no one else can know
about it otherwise everyone else that
hears about is going to make the same
thing but if the only thing that in your
business has value that's difficult to
do is keeping that one idea secret then
you know people can still duplicate the
idea is probably something that needs to
be developed further in my opinion
anybody else have thoughts on that
question I agree I agree with you but
there's also you know a time crash you
know if you yeah it's easy to implement
it if you understand the market
understand how to get to market have the
financing have the development behind
you and so someone that is driving and
building this you know they'd probably
have 18 months to really get it to the
next it you know get a head start so I
think that you know you do have to be
motivated with some urgency to
prioritize what the two or three things
we need to do in order to get it to this
stage in six months or
from whatever I focus a lot on that
still now and so I don't know if that
helps it a little bit but that thing you
want that again be with you today Google
yeah I mean and also define your head
start does your head you know as your
head start towards a patent or towards
some sort of technology development is
done or having a you know getting into a
good subset of a market or whatever how
much property you know I think it's
important to understand patent law but
i'm not a big huge patent fin primarily
summer in the software world and there's
so much time involved there and I feel
like two years from now or three years
from now the world is entirely different
so you began we have a product now we
when we do consulting work we retain all
the IP to most of the work that we do we
have a company that's spinning out now
college that's basically implementing
this thing called chalk bought that we
built for Nike that sprays message on
the ground that's a very specific
hardware IP or some hardware IP
associated with that but I really feel
like with ideas you should be willing to
throw them out there and race to finish
them because everyone's having ideas are
not the idea of the Epiphany I'm really
not into like I feel like my ideas come
from a whole bunch of other things I
know and experience and you build upon
them and then the only thing that makes
you different is if you finish them
because everyone has ideas all the time
but if you're the first to finish it you
know kudos to you you're going to get
something out there and it may fail but
but just do it otherwise that's why
everyone sits around and says all I
could have I could have invented that or
I could have drawn that what you didn't
write and whoever did want so that's the
yeah putting the work it takes work push
up here
when you do with mentors and I guess I'm
really getting used to you because your
company I wouldn't do with mentors what
the mechanism to use to determine or
distinguish between good advice and bad
advice especially when you get
conflicting advice are you asking cuz
Art's not here anymore I'm just kidding
just kidding um but i'll actually defer
that to the the panel but just quickly
to answer i would say that the best
advice in the early stages for us was
advice that was free and somebody
approaches you and wants a piece of your
company or want some compensation in
return for being an adviser or being a
board member when you're very early it's
usually going to be bad advice but i'll
pass it off to the to the panel if
anybody wants to answer that i think the
first off you have to find a mentor that
or or group mentors that fit what you're
trying to do if you're you know if
you're like me making software and the
people that your mentors are they build
hardware that may not be the right group
of people once you find that sort of
group i think the the person or the
individuals who give you not not just
free advice but but advice that seems to
make a logical sense towards you know
whatever your whatever your business
goals are are the ones that you want to
fall i mean if your gut tells you that
it's wrong it may be that they're not
understanding what it is that you're
you're asking or you're trying to get
information on or they may have some
alternate genda we had I've experienced
that in two companies where they you
know the people that I thought were
trying to help me work helping me at all
they just had an alternate plan and they
wanted me to fit into it and so you kind
of have to keep that in mind
anyone else say something we have over
you I talk a lot we um I feel like you
have to observe hone your instincts and
get really really smart about who you
pay attention to I actually forgot what
I was going to say now is cuz I'm
thinking about you so no all right we'll
move on not in the back I did a
generation while you're a student
because I often had a student here
you're kind of in case in a bowl and we
don't really see other
David you look like you I mean all over
that one to start it's really I think
it's really important to read a lot and
kind of be up to date with what's going
on around the world and look at what
other businesses are doing what's going
on there and also sometimes you can just
come up with an idea out of nowhere and
sort of explore around that I mean
there's there's a guess I don't really
have very specific advice on it i'll
give you one listen a bunch if you're
walking around campus and you hear a
bunch of people complaining about the
same thing they might have an idea that
i'm not saying you do but it's possible
you know you want to target where
people's pain points are and what what
are people gonna you know water people
unhappy about and sometimes those things
can translate into businesses 24 hours
in a day let's leave although i guess
i'm still student i was fortunate enough
that i'm studying something that's very
relevant to you i'm working on
information systems and you know
software development is very relevant
and I tried to get all my professors
involved in what I was doing as a
business so they'll be supportive of
what I'm working on and that has helped
a bit of course I think some majors are
more difficult than others in terms of
time commitments and it's definitely a
difficult to get a balance there
the statue you also get funding and how
you're still at how you are funding your
ventures at this up to this point some
of the major stumbling block some of the
sort of baked sort of rolls on and love
me some insight particular i just didn't
follow has anyone on our panel raised
venture funding you have maybe we could
start there there's really you know they
divide money into basically three stages
you got your friends family or angel and
your and your venture money each come
with different fun pieces your friends
and family money obviously you're taking
people's money that you know so there's
the guilt trip aspect involved and you
know it's the generally the earliest age
of money so you're not you know it's
it's the most risky people talk a lot
about smart money and dumb money the the
biggest thing that that i can offer that
is that i was working we were raising
money and we had to I wouldn't say
competing offer two different offers and
one was somebody who was really
interested in the technology didn't care
so much about the people was not a
Pittsburgh was not somebody who was
around Pittsburgh and they had a
slightly better deal we actually end up
taking me the other the other deal who
was not that because they were local
individuals and they really believed
from the team when it comes to
introductions and what comes to people
that you need to meet in order to get
your business off the ground you really
want to evaluate I mean these
individuals may be giving you money but
you're also using them for their
connections and so you want to find
people that have cash that can give you
an open doors that you otherwise
couldn't get to venture capital firms
are very good at that as well when you
get to the later stages people that can
open doors for you or critical let's try
to squeeze in a few more questions here
and then I think we might have to get
moving on but let's go here this is
where Nathan you have a lot of
experience with
salting have you ever considered
building a personal brand versus a
business well um we actually so we're
that we're a company business model
that's never supposed to exist but we
managed to raise like half a million
dollars under it and at this point this
year we're going to close with a million
dollars of revenue this year which is
which is great for us so what we do is
our business model that so securities
that we do this consulting side of
development we try to build a brand out
of it the reason we built a brand is
primarily so that we can compete with
advertising agencies and try to go
directly to clients advertisers so that
we can do development work then retain
the IP and ideally license or
commercialize that IP very much like a
university model we're very much like an
art group / university research project
no I don't think our brands worth
anything right now other than other than
our personal marketing which we pay a
lot of attention to the other table
marketing is we pay attention to every
one that writes about us or blogs about
us we document everyone if they have a
position that we care about we send the
personal letters t-shirts and we stay in
touch with them and from that we've been
able to get our writing I write a lot
about sort of design and interaction we
get that published in industry magazines
and stuff so we sort of stay our brand
does matter to us primarily I'm just
entertaining new clients or getting to
climbs great let's go right here this is
part of a comment or question
there was a lot of discussion about
listening to the customer I'd like to
point out an alternative perspective I
get your opinion on it sometimes I found
that you want to do opposite of
listening to the customer you want to
lead the customer and show the customer
thing is that they're not seen in a
perfect example that planet manager so I
have a lot of great great stories for
example of this Polaroid what are their
customers 10 can you make it come out
faster comes out faster can you make it
can you make it color it comes out with
color can you make it sing when you
click the button that nobody was asking
before digital / you that was so in your
comment about about that aspect of
actually going against the grain and
actually showing the customer with it
they don't even want it doesn't exist I
take a stab at that because you know
we're going through that we have gone
through that we're going through that
now as we sort of enter the market in a
big way with with our products it you
know we're trying to sell disruptive
technology they're used to doing things
one way they're used to buying things
one way they're used to results one way
and trying to go in and and figure that
out is something you have to pay
attention to but but really figure out
ways to ask them questions and leave
them along to what the solution is you
know if you're solving there you know
like my product for instance at the end
of the day it has nothing to do with
video games at all it has to do with
significantly reducing time of training
and accidents and behaviors and these
are things that companies call me about
a lot in a large utility companies will
say you know we've got guys in the field
we've got have flexible we can't let
these guys do electrical work for the
third thing they can't go wrong so how
do we solve that
I don't know if that helps but really
understanding how things work now and
then working from there that wasn't good
the Polaroid is a good example I was I
use this phrase squinting at technology
a lot which is really about like I want
to work with people who don't understand
that the what a piece of technology is
designed or its purpose or its rule set
is but can squint at it and figure out
what it's opportunity is we have clients
it's one of the benefits of working with
clients clients walk into our door all
the time and say I need an iphone app I
need a facebook app I need or whatever
right and there are many people who sell
them those things but if you can truly
listen and I think we mean listening in
a way of just not asking them to say I
need it black and I needed to spin I
need it to emote and just saying what is
it they really need and that's what I
think your Polaroid example does can you
figure out what the real sort of pain is
and what they're really trying to get at
and if you can do that for us we try to
do it with our clients and then it helps
us sort of think about it in our own
products as well but that's the hard
thing you're like to see what do they
really mean by that also the whole
adoption curve plays into this you know
we sort of analyze the psychology of
who's going to get on board early on and
then we focus our time on them because
it's not going to be you know when the
iphone first comes out everyone's not
going to buy they're going to wait a
while and then the adopters will slowly
and then you know sooner or later it's
like well yeah it's obvious i'm gonna
everyone's doing it that's right
crossing the chasm exactly exactly sure
I think we have questioned way in the
back I'm sorry one more question for way
in the back
so now my position is on our people in
advising and managing and over
so the question is how do you know when
when to say when appointed me call da
how to pop you about designing about
injecting I need to let you know one
setting a deadline you know when you
should possibly that's good good
question who wants to take that one oh
you making progress i'm going to make
progress yeah i think you know one of
the things that I think we welcome is
you know incremental progress towards
some goal as long as you're heading in
the right direction you know and you can
keep yourself funded to go that
direction you should be okay I you know
if you spend too much time think about
what your back and plan is then you're
not spending up time what your actual
plane is and then you you're just you're
just some of trouble yeah exactly yeah
yeah i think that like for me that's why
i work i have attention deficit disorder
basically and that's why I work with
software and things I can deploy really
quickly because I've been in that case I
spent two and half years of research for
that I came here to implement this idea
that I've been working on since 2000 I
wanted to put points on a map and share
it right and I have the experience of
spending five years of my adult life
trying to commercialize thing right one
year is a company three years as or
trying to get this thing out and get
people to use it we never had real use
so that's a that's a wasted that's a
really bad failure good failures or what
I have right now so don't have a failure
where you're not able to see like when
someone can actually use this thing
right and in my case I'm not able to
deal with that in some cases you know
medical device clearly you have to have
a really long vision and have the
patience that I don't have but that's
why sort of i'm attracted to my industry
because i can move very quickly fail
quickly so i never want to see that
six-year thing happen like if that
starts to happen I
on a new idea one on that note we're
going to wrap it up but thank you all
for your questions and thanks to our
panelists